I would love for you to recount if you
were willing to what you witnessed back
in five to seven years ago I guess
not long huh yeah
we came back and when we came back to
what happens is you'll start upgrading
systems or repairing things yada yada we
were upgrading we were a rare Lot number
I think it's called where essentially we
were engineered or manufactured so that
we could be upgraded later it was a
small amount of aircraft that were
upgradable essentially these are Super
Hornet super hard yeah and so we started
upgrading our Raiders when we got back
which was awesome because of my like
level three check arrives can be so much
easier with this radar than than what
the older ones but anyways long story
short we were flying with our older
radar we weren't seeing anything really
of note and then we upgrade our Radars
and then started detecting objects in
our areas there's two conversations here
those and that's the one first
conversation I'm having is what my
real-time experience was there's some
things I've learned since then and I'm
gonna hold those but so just to be clear
that um I'm just kind of talking about
my interactions first person Observer so
okay we were thinking these were radar
errors you know because you get false
track hits on Earth The Radars at least
was my assumption that this was probably
a false track of some type until we
started getting uh returns at least on
our camera or a flare system 18th year
at least for me at the time was like
okay well if we're seeing these on clear
now being correlated we have to assume
these physical objects after the fact
again this is like later knowledge I had
spoke with other Pilots interviewed one
of my podcasts and I talked with others
who got vectored into traffic that was
interesting which place stationary
objects and that's the majority of what
we were seeing but he's stationary
ground tracker okay
um ground track yep and uh
he was asked to go and go check out the
object essentially this was over by the
Dare the uh range so he went off and
intercepted apg-73 radar he essentially
had the quarter moon kind of Zoom it in
zoom in the radar but went away
backwards so talk about the near
encounter or whatever yeah so it was two
aircraft with four people total only the
first aircraft the lead aircraft saw it
they were flying to go do a mission I
don't know what it was out in the areas
two of them flying side by side they
went the way it works is there's a
single point that's the entrance to the
working areas at a very particular
altitude and everyone leaves a thousand
feet below that or vice versa I forget
but either way they you know we're
tightening up their formation
accelerating now they're above 10 000
feet you can accelerate above 250 300
knots and so they're accelerating
probably 350 closing in the formation
and then the lead just to see something
Go Hard by his aircraft and what he
described was a dark gray or Black Cube
inside of a instead of a clear sphere
that was stationary with respect to him
or so he couldn't tell now I'm gonna go
back a little bit because we had
described it wasn't perfectly accurate I
said it flew past them right but that
was just a relative view so it's our
understanding that it was stationary at
that location and that they flew through
it but it of course it appeared that way
to them plus their separation we tipped
to wingtip pretty tight I've been using
about you know 100 to 150 feet as an
average because they were probably
tightening it up to get in there and
stuff so you don't know the exact
distance but phone there okay so so go
on so then they yeah so the object you
know it's hard to you know really
objectively think is that they're going
by like that especially with a surprise
and all that so confidence and the data
is you know somewhat low here I'll say
but you know he described it he thought
it came closer to his aircraft and so he
described it as like five to fifteen
feet in diameter that was what he could
kind of glean from you know seeing it
Zip by his aircraft at such close
distance if you're hard to tell the size
of object unless you know what it is so
yeah I mean that was that was
essentially it he they turned around
they canceled the flight after that they
weren't confident that they're you know
hit or essentially to clear their nose
they were in the ready room with all
their gear on when they came back and at
this point we've been seeing and talking
about them enough where he's just like I
don't hit one of those effing things we
all knew what he was talking about then
we were kind of obligated because it was
so close that we had to file a safety
report and kind of the chit chat in a
squadron with the commanding officer and
whatnot was that you know okay you need
more UFO UAP I mean I didn't know that
term UAP I didn't think it was I mean it
was a term but it wasn't something that
we were but you know we thought perhaps
these were some type of classified
program that maybe you know had
inadvertently operation where they
shouldn't have or whatever maybe we
could kind of
get a message to them that they were now
you know this was going to lead to a
mishap if they didn't take care of it
and get their you know their stuff in
order and it happened multiple times
right there were multiple sightings of
the similar type of variety from
different Pilots yep okay
foreign